وميض من
الضوء فوق الظلام الدامس
الذي يجتاح غزة كل
ليلة، ووعد صارخ بمزيد من الموت والدمار،
والحصار المستمر وانقطاع
الاتصالات، مما أدى إلى إغراق غزة في
صمت مخيف، ما ظهر من مقطع فيديو صغير حتى
الآن يرسم صورة للدمار الذي
أحدثته إسرائيل.
مشاهد القصف المتواصل لخسائر غير مفهومة
غطت الجثث، وهي الأحدث بين
آلاف
الضحايا، تقول إسرائيل إنها تستهدف
حماس، وتوسع الآن
عملياتها البرية، ردًا على
هجمات حماس الإرهابية التي وقعت في 7 أكتوبر/تشرين الأول،
والتي خلفت ما لا يقل عن 1400 قتيل وأسر أكثر
من 200 آخرين.  رهائن داخل غزة
ولكن في القطاع المحاصر،
عدد القتلى الفلسطينيين يرتفع أيضًا
مع كل
غارة جوية، الوضع هنا رهيب،
دمرت منازلنا في الغارات الجوية،
قُتل ستة من أفراد عائلاتنا،
فماذا يمكننا أن نفعل، نحن جميعًا  لقد كان
هذا هو المشهد يوم الجمعة في
مستشفى ألفا، وهو أكبر مستشفى في غزة، وهو الآن
ليس شريان حياة لآلاف
المرضى فحسب، بل ملاذًا لعشرات
الآلاف بما في ذلك الأطفال الذين شردتهم
الحرب.
لا نطلب الماء، نحن نطلب
الأمان من أجل الأمن، رجالنا ونساءنا
وأطفالنا، لقد قُتلوا جميعًا، وقد
جاء الكثير منهم على أمل أن
تظل المستشفيات ملاذًا آمنًا، لكن
إسرائيل الآن توصف هذا الملاذ الآمن دون أي
دليل يمكن التحقق منه.
كهدف محتمل، المباني الحمراء كما ذكرت والتي
تستخدمها حماس هو ادعاء رفضه
المسؤولون الفلسطينيون في غزة الذين يتهمون
إسرائيل بتزوير المعلومات الاستخبارية ويقولون إن
المستشفى يستخدم فقط لعلاج
المرضى ولكن هناك مخاوف من عواقب مثل هذه
الادعاءات.  من قبل الكثيرين، فإن أي
اقتراح بأن هذا المستشفى يمكن
اعتباره هدفًا مشروعًا من قبل إسرائيل
للأطباء الذين يعرفون المستشفى جيدًا
هو تحذير من إراقة دماء لا يمكن تصورها. لقد
كنت أعمل في جميع أنحاء الشفاء
في الطابق السفلي في العيادات المختلفة
في المباني المختلفة.  لقد كنت
هناك ليلا ونهارا في زمن الحرب
في كل
مكان ولم أر قط
أي شيء يمكن أن يبدو أو
يعمل مثل بعض مراكز القيادة
في الغارات الجوية الإسرائيلية التي
تدمر هذا الجيب المدمر بالفعل، مما يزيد
القصف المدفعي الآن من
الدمار الذي يلحق بالناس  من غزة تمزقهم
دائرة الحداد المستمرة وما زالوا
يكافحون من أجل فهم هذا
الموت الكابوس الذي لا نهاية له والمنسوج الآن في
نسيج
حياتهم NE Basher CNN في أمان الأردن ش